well in other news we're talking about
uh bill burr on saturday live
oh yeah that's a good event went hard in
the paint went hard in the painting no
but it's bill being bill that's right
people are doing these woke dummies
you're like how can you allow this guy
inside our lives like
oh you don't know about bill bill burr
like that's bill burr being bill burke
that's what's fantastic about it i feel
like people
give other people too much credit for
why they're upset
it's like [ __ ] chill relax it's some
jokes
one headline i saw is jokes and but his
intense
jokes and his intent is to rile you
dummies up yeah and
look what they do they do exactly what
he what what he says they do
they do exactly that what do you say who
told bill burr he's a straight white man
should try to tackle homophobia and
racism in the worst way possible in this
snl
monologue i had to turn off after five
minutes you gave it five minutes damn it
the monitor was only the monologue was
like seven minutes
you lasted that long but you know what
you know what's so funny whenever people
they people pick out [ __ ] like he's he
said a bunch of stuff
but they only pick and choose what
because you know what they're mad about
exactly that it's like well okay and i'm
not listening
people can get offended that's the they
have people are [ __ ]
can you imagine watching a saturday
monologue
and then tweeting how upset you are
about it that's hilarious
when you guys did that you wouldn't be
here on monday i swear
if anybody in this room did that i'd be
like dude we can't have you around yeah
why we just can't okay you can't exactly
you can't be part of the group
you can't can't you like a youtube
comment at that yeah and did these
people act like bill burr owe them
something what does he owe you
[ __ ] nothing but what you you jim
talk about and being upset
that's exactly his point of the model
yeah yeah how white women hijacked this
woke movement and the black lives matter
so funny so funny
he goes and they saw him do that
right before the pandemic happened i saw
him do it at the comedy store it's great
oh it's so
great in this take on the first lady so
funny yeah
so [ __ ] funny but it's bill bird
being bill burke yeah
so it's like the only people that are
upset are people that don't know bill
burst you don't know um
you don't know anything about it but
you've never heard of them never heard
of them and you're not gonna be fans
anyway so you suck
and then the other people who like it
are his fans anyway so
it didn't really it's just like yeah it
does it does it's a win-win for bill
yeah it's a win-win
but also what they say he took a page
out of louis ck's
uh book there because louis c.k has been
doing saturday live
hot take monologues for a hot second i
mean lucy
on there he's probably done it four
times oh and every time it's a hot take
that
riles everybody up everybody talks about
it and they keep booking them
it's just what but it's what to me
what's dope about it
is it's authentic right it's like that
and saturday live knows booking bill
burr like you're getting you know
they know what they're going to get he's
not going to tailor it towards yeah he's
like he's going to give you bill burr
and he killed it like all the secrets
by the way the dinner when they kept
mispronunciating the words
so yeah people get round up you know
what'd you do this weekend
[Laughter]
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son